y el problema dice lo siguiente ir a
resolver la ecuación 5 más la raíz de x
14 esto es igual a x 7 usando los
siguientes pasos
el primer paso dice resto 5 de ambos
lados por lo tanto dijo 5 lo paso del
otro lado y 7-5 es igual a 2 después
elevó al cuadrado ambos lados de la
ecuación y la raíz con el cuadrado se
van por lo tanto me queda x + 14 y x + 2
lo elevó al cuadrado usando la fórmula
del binomio al cuadrado perfecto
expandió el lado derecho por lo tanto x
+ 2 elevado al cuadrado es x cuadrada
más dos veces el primero pues segundo
que es 4 x + 4 después restó x + 14 de
ambos lados por lo tanto el x + 14 lo
paso del otro lado y te queda 4 x - x te
queda 3x y después 4 menos 14 me queda
menos diez después factor hizo el lado
derecho de la ecuación si se dan cuenta
5 x menos 2 me da menos 10 y 5 menos dos
me da 3
el siguiente paso dice uso la propiedad
del producto cero para resolver la
ecuación quedando las raíces x igual a
menos 5
o x2 en este paso irán observo lo
siguiente uso la regla del producto 0
que dice que si dos números
multiplicados te dan 0 o el primero es 0
o el segundo es 0 pero en este caso
tenemos una multiplicación de binomios
por lo tanto el primer binomio es igual
a 0 x + 5 es igual a 0 en su dado caso x
menos 2 es igual a 0
si x + 5 es igual a cero por lo tanto x
igual a menos 5 es una raíz y si x menos
2 es igual a cero por lo tanto x igual a
2 también es una raíz y después lo que
hizo ya que había encontrado las raíces
es checar sus respuestas puso al menos 5
cada vez que encontraba x en la ecuación
original y dijo 5 más la raíz de menos 5
más 14 es igual a menos 575 mandó a raíz
de 9 es igual a 253 es igual a 2 y dijo
no está no sirve es falsa porque esta
igualdad no se cumple vamos a utilizar
la segunda raíz 5 más la raíz de dos más
14 es igual a 2 más 75 más de raíz de
dos más 14 16 5 mazda veis de 16 es
igual a 9
por lo tanto 54 utilizando la
dispositiva va a ser igual a 9
esta si se cumple para finalizar irán
concluyó lo siguiente cómo se cumple la
segunda igualdad por lo tanto x igual a
2 es la respuesta de esta ecuación ahora
bien en este vídeo nos piden que
juzguemos se irán resolvió bien o mal la
ecuación lo que nos piden es saber si
este ejemplo es una forma de
razonamiento deductivo y explicar por
qué sí o por qué no lo es ahora bien
quiero que te des cuenta de una cosa
nosotros empezamos con un hecho o con
una ecuación la cual le damos el valor
de verdadero y si empiezas con un hecho
y después otras pasos lógicos
operaciones matemáticas o razonamientos
lógicos para obtener de nuevo un hecho
esto es un razonamiento deductivo no
estamos estimando no estamos
generalizando no estamos asumiendo que
tal vez pase algo simplemente empezamos
con algo que es verdadero y obtenemos de
nuevo algo verdadero y esto es la mejor
idea de un razonamiento deductivo
empezamos con una ecuación la cual le
damos el valor de verdadero y por lo
tanto su respuesta también va a ser
verdadera y seguramente te estás
preguntando porque la raíz x igual a
menos 5 nos dé un resultado falso
y bueno lo que sucedió en este caso es
que tenemos la raíz de 9 y tomamos la
raíz positiva eso sí no vayan a olvidar
que cuando sacamos raíz o aplicamos el
operador raíz cuadrada tenemos dos
posibles raíces una positiva y una
negativa más aún si nosotros nos fijamos
en esta ecuación con la raíz negativa me
quedaría 5 menos 3 lo cual si es 2 al
final todo este malentendido se originó
cuando nosotros en el tercer paso
elevamos a ambos lados al cuadrado y
bueno para finalizar y retomar lo que
hablábamos del razonamiento deductivo si
partimos de una idea que es verdadera no
generalizamos si obtenemos una idea que
también es verdadera eso es un
razonamiento deductivo